ah hidden away is my style she only a
madman would take all this mission what
can I found me I'm crazy as hell I get a
good crotch shot there yeah yeah it's
got the shaft I'm not actually like
familiar with everything I'm going to
turn this down too easy just for the
stream because it's hard to play and
scream the same time and as you all know
I'm not very good at old video games
despite loving as usual you're playing
this on the Retron 5 yes pin this on the
Retron 5 we're going to start giving
away older retron systems on megabit in
the next couple weeks I've met with the
guys from hyper kin and they are keen to
do that so if you guys like to play old
games you might want to get one of those
systems
good also the UN is like a real dicks
for just sending one person to do this
oh no I got this do I yep
alright
so you're fighting the bosses you go
along he just keeps disappearing or no
no joke you'll see yeah i'm talking like
the real stuff boner
never ceases doing the goodness games
look
my bombs and back in the Super Nintendo
you still have so many of these really
good third party like Capcom was for
putting up just a lot of really cool
stuff as opposed to the wii u we have
now
it's an apt observation
okay let's get ten specially out of oh
oh yeah yeah cool the same states are
really nice they do give you the
opportunity to you know see the whole
game we're good at it it like it is a
normal person not someone who can just
oh my god these guys are moving up and
down as i move along that's disorienting
and difficult to deal with hahaha this
was my April oh maybe you're supposed to
destroy something yeah maybe it would be
that your mom I knew I just switched
over
like this seems like a horrible mission
for a fighter like this would you want
to call in a bomber and made me slid out
my give it to make crush
maybe nobody's which it's not that you
can press dad the submarine pops out of
the world it's going to be like it's a
shark coming out to attack what uh-uh
there you see that's all the submarine
has to do to win what don't come out
submarine he stayed out who's the cop
told you had a submarine who you can
only get us when we call that's just
doing that oh yeah he's really good at
getting you that thing yeah I got no
didn't get screwed I'm screwed it's just
like a shirt this is no it kind of opens
up as it jumps out of the water it like
you can see its mouth rawr what bar is
easy it opens up and shoot something
eight I just wanted to die so bad work
fine yeah it should work just fine I
don't know that there's anything special
about that card this little sucks
attention all units bandits coming in
scramble and chase alarm level again I
don't think they understand what bandits
mean cuz these guys are actually really
well we're needed to have a lot of good
technology I'm trying to talk to me it's
not one you can have a conversation now
is a conversation would be shut up shop
kind of like what you want to say now uh
yes shut the [ __ ] up it's the game not
here this band is man well then they
have like tiger stripes plane Wow yeah
oh god there's some good that's going
see this guy behind me I feel like you
should be on my team oh yeah wow what a
jerk they're firing at you they're
really bad at fighting you I'm pretty
bad that's a really cool effect though
with the clouds they're gonna go down I
don't like it because the planes move to
like there's no way that they could
react that fast oh yeah it doesn't make
sense whoa oh that's just [ __ ] I got
hit maybe once necro Tron says I don't
think I remember ever beating this game
but i remember playing the early levels
a lot it's a lot like my experience
so much damage so much damage but this
has its so it's an arcade game I i would
assume you could probably beat it pretty
quickly once you put your good at it
there's I'm so no I don't believe it's
that long in the game it's just really
difficult there's the Retron 5 let you
turn on yes it does and she might be fun
to dive into the game being stupid to
have I'm supposed to get around out how
am I supposed to deal with that chase
them off what's on his forehead why does
he have a hex on his forehead he's
really serious it's like a pro road
Brown you have one of those to do
dimensionally I got Fred just a deep
crevice I get just like a crevice but
it's between my eyebrows I'm valley yeah
like a valley of strips you watch Peter
while he's playing this you'll be able
to see the valley formed between design
it's true it grows the girlfriend is
very aware when it happens
what are you worried about are you doing
much better
switch nope got to that to this
yeah bend it now tell you guys
what I can't do what haha purple no
someone says the game takes about half
an hour to be master the hero could
probably beat the game twice forget out
of your sucks of it fortunately we're
video game professionals and this is
uneasy this is uneasy just so this is a
reminder I forgot yeah thanks yeah all
right Greg gates all right so these guys
are firing at you from the ground
they're gonna have like a big brother
it's gonna fire Wow [ __ ] I like fires
everywhere you go good nice yeah yeah
necro Tron there is no input lag with
the Retron 5 it's one of the great parts
about it actually is not everyone has a
CRT d CRT TV and hooking up you know old
school consoles hdtvs does create that
lag which when the threshold for success
is so tiny gold games it's
kind of a pain das as we saw a few times
it's such as on donkey kong country when
I played that mine card level oh no I
think me and max over in turn max played
that like 120 times could not beat it oh
damn it damn it no gonna have to kick me
off the air because I'm not going to
give up fudge look good all right talk
about super mega loser says I need her
used to be really good at game time I'll
just die does die no one likes you least
of all that you in there really pretty
though that those are like stylish ships
all about fashion the cockpits kind of
green oh yes God
home